Tonight on our very
first episode, we're talking
about one of Long Island New
York's most haunted places with
over three centuries of history,
the Country House Restaurant in
Stony Brook. We'll hear the sad
story of Annette Williamson's
death and search the Obadiah
Davis Cemetery to find out who
really has been haunting the
property and spooking owners,
workers, and patrons alike over
the years, and along the way
we'll learn to never trust
French psychics. It's Wednesday
at 9pm. Okay guys, I have a
great story to start the show
off. Over the weekend, I was
visiting family for my grandma's
birthday and my Uncle Joe from
Long Island mentioned that
there's a billion haunted places
on Long Island. We love Uncle
Joe. We do. He's great, but he
pointed me in the direction of
some stories what's considered
the most haunted location on
Long Island. It's called the
Country House Restaurant and I
want to tell you guys a story
about the ghosts that haunted
and why the story that's told
might not be true. Oh,
scandalous. Yeah, I like stories
with different perspectives.
Yeah, I bet you do. Okay, so
actually we might have passed by
this actually when we went on
our trip to Long Island over the
summer. It's in Stony Brook. We
were in Lake the Hamptons. Sauer
is pretty far out east way past
this, but we might have driven
right past this road, right past
this restaurant. For those who
don't know Long Island, it's on
the north shore of Long Island,
which is the huge island to the
east of New York City. It's not
part of New York City, but two
boroughs of New York City,
Brooklyn and Queens, are on the
island, but they don't really
consider it Long Island. People
would be very offended if you
said you were from Long Island
if you're from Queens or
Brooklyn. So do you guys know
how old European settlements on
Long Island are? If you had to
give a random guess? Well, 400
years. Okay, I thought you guys
can be wrong. That's right. It's
like 300 years old since the 16,
that's almost 400, honestly,
1600s, mid 1600s. Right. The
water above it, the Long Island
Sound is where everyone would do
like whaling, killing whales and
taking their meat and selling
them whatever. It was like
really nice water for that. So
it became really popular early
1600s. So a lot of the buildings
there are hundreds of hundreds
of years old. The building we're
talking about today was built in
1710. Oh, yeah. So pre-America.
Yeah, pre-America, basically
what happened, a lot of New
England settlers came down to
Long Island mid 1600s for the
farming and for the whaling.
This is like prime time for a
few different things,
Freemasonry, secret societies,
and a little bit later on,
spiritualism. So I think Nick
and I really know about
spiritualism. Aaron, what do you
know about spiritualism? I'll be
honest, not that much. That's
really the idea simply that you
can talk to the dead. Oh, okay.
That's where mediums, the idea
of mediumship started. Sances
and all kinds of things like
that. In America, at least, it
started sweeping the nation in
like late 1700s and mid, all the
way through the 1800s. And it
became really popular for people
to do séances and just shut the
lights off and use Ouija boards
and the precursors to Ouija
boards and do table tipping and
all that. And mediums started
appearing claiming that they
could talk to the dead and you
can pay them and they'll talk to
your grandma and they'll
manifest your dog that died and
it'll lick your face in the dark
and stuff like that. It was kind
of like parlor games more to an
extent. It's a form of
entertainment more than
anything. Yeah. And
interestingly, this all really
started in like upstate New
York, not too far from where we
are right now in Heidsville,
which is like in between
Syracuse and Rochester. Oh, it's
more western than central. Yeah,
it's actually really west. Yeah.
Yeah. So this building built
around 1710 by the Davis family
and they owned it at least four
generations, pretty long time.
And again, this is on the North
Shore of Long Island, pretty
good farmland, but Stony Brook
really wasn't a well-known
place. It was kind of like
backwater town for the first
good chunk of it because no one
really wanted to go there. It
was difficult to travel there. A
bunch of poor farmers. No one
really cared. This building, the
Davis family must have been
pretty rich because it was huge,
very large building, two stories
and pretty active throughout the
1700s. It housed British
soldiers at some point. It was
used as a town meeting place, as
a stagecoach stop. During the
Revolutionary War, it was used
as a contact point for the
Culper Spy Ring, which was an
American spy ring that George
Washington started. There would
be spies that came in and out.
So imagine there's this
beautiful, and if you guys want
to click the link I sent you in
the Discord, which will be in
the show notes, you could see
this building. It's a restaurant
now. It was only a restaurant
starting in like 1970, 1980.
That's fairly recent for me
being, was it just a historical?
Oh, yeah, it was purchased
historical building for all that
time. Passed down through a few
different families. Yeah. And
it's right off, it's on the
corner of two main roads, Main
Street and like Route 25A, which
is that classic long road that
all Long Islanders know on the
North Shore. So yeah, a lot of
history here. Let's talk about
some of the weird stuff, right?
Because there's a lot here.
Imagine this nice house. It's
kind of on the hill. The Davis
family, Obadiah Davis was the
guy who bought it, bought the
land and built the property. He
built a family cemetery right
behind it on a little hill
overlooking the building. It's
where his family was buried.
That's still there to that day,
the cemetery. Do you think the
cemetery being there might
contribute to some of the
happenings that you're going to
discuss today? The cemetery does
feature very strongly in the
story. In fact, I found who's
buried in that cemetery, because
there are some conflicting
stories about the ghosts that
want this place and who's buried
here. I found the gravestones
and pictures of the gravestones
and some things don't line up. I
couldn't find where the cemetery
was actually, like physically on
Google maps or on maps. There's
no record of it. You probably
want to keep it. I actually
called them up today. Oh, wow.
No, I called them up today on
the phone. And I said, hi guys,
where's the Obadiah Davis
cemetery? And they told me,
they're like, oh, it's right
behind the stables next to the
parking lot. Oh, that's more
open of them than I would
expect. Yeah, I was like, oh,
oh, OK. Though from what I've
heard from all the research I
did, you can't just really, they
don't really appreciate you just
walking there. It's a very small
cemetery. It's like 50 tombs,
basically. It's kind of how it
goes from most cemeteries,
though, unless you have like
family there, you can't just
wander about. Yeah, it's not
like a public cemetery that
anyone can just to visit or even
be buried in. They're all very
old, like all 17, 1800 deaths.
So, yeah, so what do people
think about this house? Well, in
the 1800s, there was a very
famous comedian named Thomas
Hathaway. He purchased the house
and lived there for a while and
he was a spiritualist. So what
did he do? Well, he started
hosting seances in this
building, right? For all the
neighborhood, all the people who
knew about this. It was more
actually a low key thing. He and
his close confidants would come
and perform seances and try to
do table tipping, which is
literally just putting your
hands on the table in the dark
and seeing if it starts tipping.
So it's kind of similar to when
people like grab the Ouija board
and push the little device onto
the letter they want. Depends.
Yeah, I mean, it depends on what
you think with it, how much
spirits we actually want. I just
want to like shake a table
around and stuff. Yeah, I think
it's a little silly. A lot of it
was revealed to be fraud at the
time. In fact, one of Thomas
Hathaway's buddies was a guy
named William Sidney Mount, who
was a pretty famous artist of
the time. And this guy was like
hardcore freemason and a
hardcore spiritualist. And he
would come to these seances and
perform these seances all the
time. He lived across the street
basically in his own haunted
house. And this guy, William
Sidney Mount, is supposedly one
of the ghosts that still haunts
the country house restaurant to
this day. It's said that he
comes back to perform seances
like he used to that he shows up
in his, it said he shows up in
his like his travel gear with
his big hat and like his long
jacket and stuff, the same dress
he would use to come to the
seances. He just keeps
contacting himself. He just
keeps contacting himself, I
guess. Yeah. It's a very vicious
cycle. A lot of famous people
would do seances here. The other
guy that I found interesting was
P.T. Barnum of the fame,
obviously like entertainer fame
of circus fame. He was a buddy
of Hathaway because Hathaway
actually worked for him as a
performer. So you had lots of
interesting people, interesting
beliefs, hosting seances, trying
to contact the dead, often
trying to contact their own dead
loved ones, claiming to
experience different things,
claiming to see things. And that
was for a short time in the mid
to late 1800s. Many of the
owners of this place have had
some interest in the occult or
spirits or something really
anything like that. So given
that, nowadays a lot is said
about this place. The current
owner who purchased it in I
think like 2005, Bob
Willemstein, he used to work
there as a busboy like 20 years
before and he worked his way all
the way up to owner eventually,
which is pretty cool. Pretty
impressive. And there are many
interviews with him where he
tells all the stories of all the
crazy things that happen to him,
that happened to his workers,
that happened to visitors, that
happened to guests. Right?
Because this is a restaurant
that we can go to. In fact, I
know someone who's gone to it.
My girlfriend Sarah has eaten
there as a kid, but supposedly
it's very fine dining. It's very
expensive. It's like 20 to $40 a
meal. But anyway, some of the
stuff that's said to happen
here, and this is considered
Long Island's most haunted
place. So people are said to
have seen the ghost of William
Sidney Mount. So a man dressed
in 1800s garb walking in the
hallways, leaving footsteps,
workers at night locking up
would see him at the corner of
their eyes. It's always like the
same description of the guy,
right? A lot of different things
with him, a lot of different
things with other male spirits
and, you know, EVP. So
recordings of disembodied voices
and all that, things like
candles being reignited. But the
most interesting story that
comes out of the country house
haunting is that of Annette
Williamson. So I'm gonna tell
you guys the story of Annette
Williamson. And then we're gonna
see if there's anything funky
about the story. So this story
comes from the owner, Bob, who
was told it by a random French
psychic who once visited the
restaurant years and years ago.
Like when he was the owner or
when he was a busboy? When he
was the owner, this random
French psychic showed up in town
late one night and was like, oh,
you're there, Auguste in your
house. That's my French accent.
It's pretty good. And Bob was
like, oh, tell me about it. And
he sat and he told this whole
story. Then Long Island's most
famous psychic duo, a lady named
Carrie Anne, now Long Island
Medium, Carrie Anne and Joe
Giaquinto is the guy. He's a
paranormal investigator and he
considers himself a medium kind
of sensitive sort of. Yeah, he
considers himself that's a good
way to put it, sensitive. They
have written books. They've
written many stories about this
because they claim to be in
contact with the ghost of
Annette Williamson. And they
verified her story and expanded
on it and documented it in books
and documentaries and local news
articles to the point where it's
one of the most famous Long
Island haunted haunting stories.
So who is Annette Williamson?
Well, it's said that the
Williamson family was a family
that owned the property at some
point during the Revolutionary
War, that period, right? And
it's that they had several
children, the oldest of which
was Annette. She was only 17
years old, so the rest of the
kids must have been pretty
young. And it's said that they
were a Dutch family living in
the area, right? And as the
story goes around the
Revolutionary War time, so just
as stuff is starting to heat up,
her parents had property in New
Jersey. I don't know why they
would want to keep property in
that dirty state. But they
wanted to check up on it and
make sure that the British
weren't destroying it or they
were in the area at the time and
they're really worried about it
there. They must have been a
wealthy family to own this
property. It was pretty large.
So what they decided to do, they
decided to leave Annette home
alone to watch over the
household and the rest of the
family while they go on a trip
to just check on the property in
New Jersey. It was a pretty
dangerous trip as again, the
British are kind of in the area.
In fact, New York, I think was
controlled by the British for a
long time during the
Revolutionary War. So it
wouldn't be an easy trip. It'd
be pretty difficult to do. And
there was actually a lot of
loyal loyalist supporters across
Long Island amongst farmers.
Stony Brook had a good mix of
pro-American citizens, but not a
good time to travel. And so
Annette was extremely distressed
by this. She begged them not to
leave, but they had to. And so
she was left alone, terrified to
fend for herself and her
siblings, not knowing when her
parents would get back. And of
course, she had nothing to
defend herself from the British.
She could do nothing. So lo and
behold, when the British came
and seeing a beautiful, huge
property demanded that Annette
allowed them to stay there. What
could she do? She had to say
yes, she couldn't do anything
and she needed to keep herself
and her siblings safe. So she
let them stay. And so it said
for the period of time where the
British troops occupied the
property, Annette spent her days
just totally, totally depressed,
wandering around, sitting in the
old field room, which is on the
second floor. Nowadays, it's
like a private party room in the
restaurant in the second floor,
sitting out, looking out the
window, just blankly staring,
waiting for her parents to
return. Every day, this is what
she would do. She'd just wander
around, just worried about her
parents, worried about keeping
after her siblings, worried
about the British, worried about
the war, and this one for a long
time. And unfortunately, her
parents never returned. They
were killed by the British in
New Jersey. And to make matters
worse, when the British left
finally, the townspeople didn't
take too kindly to her housing
their enemy and they accused her
of being a British spy. And an
angry mob broke down the doors
and without any sort of trial,
murdered her and the rest of the
family and pulled blood. Like
all the other siblings? Yes,
yes. So keep in mind the
interesting parts of the story,
right? Now, there are
disagreeing records on whether
she was hanged in the old field
room near the fireplace or
murdered outside. But that's the
story. She died and ever since
then, there have been countless,
countless, countless encounters
with her. The owner, Bob, tells
stories of closing up at night,
turning around the corner, and
bumping into a full apparition
of a young woman, blonde hair,
blue eyes, very pale, who turns
to look at him, is startled, has
a look of fear and surprise, and
just dissipates in front of him.
He's had stuff like his tie
clip, which is a oddly specific
thing, disappear and reappear on
the fireplace where she was
supposedly hanged. But then it
gets even weirder because
there's actually many, many,
many encounters that have had
many witnesses. He was once
closing out the restaurant with
an old friend who was very much
a skeptic and didn't believe in
any of this sort of stuff at
all. They're sitting down when
supposedly, and this is from the
person himself, a chair in the
restaurant is lifted up and
thrown at him. Oh, we got some
poltergeist stuff going on. Yes.
And as they turn to look, they
catch a glimpse of a white
dress, kind of flapping right
around like a corner as if
someone just escaped the room.
Well, they call a glimpse of
her. So there's this seeming
like poltergeist kind of
trickery stuff going on with the
hiding of the tie pin as well.
But then you said he also just
ran into her basically, and she
dissipated. That doesn't sound
as aggressive as the poltergeist
stuff. So if that's true, as far
as hauntings go, I mean, you
said it's the most haunted
place. There could just be
multiple things at work there
because it wouldn't make, I
don't feel like it would make
sense for for there to be
poltergeist activity from the
same thing that got startled and
then vanished. That's a, keep
that in mind. That's an
interesting point. Well, to add
to that, were any of the
siblings, like her sister, like
could it have been one of the
sisters instead of her or was
the account that it was probably
a net? All the encounters assume
that it's a net. The stories
never give details on how many
siblings there were or how young
they were and how many guys, how
many girls. So it's always
assumed to be a net. Basically
anything that happens in the
house is chalked up to a net to
a point where it's kind of like
advertised for this restaurant
that you'll get to experience
the ghost of a net because
evidently she's very kind to
children. One day when a family
was dining there, evidently with
a young girl, like four or five
years old, the little girl would
keep getting up and trying to
get into the men's bathroom. And
Bob the owner eventually came
over and was like, hi, can you
please tell your daughter to
stop? We can't, you know, it's
causing a scene. Just let her
know she can't do that. And the
parents were really embarrassed
and mom was like, you know,
sweetie, you can't go there.
That's not for girls. That's for
guys. Why are you trying to go
there? And the girl said, my
friend, my friend's trying to
play hide and seek with me. She
wants me to follow her over
there. And they're like, what?
And they asked the kid to
describe the girl or the friend
and she's like, that's a young
girl, young lady, blonde hair,
blue eyes. And she gives a
description exactly matching the
story of Annette Williamson.
Right. In that case, it's like a
more friendly story, but there
are less friendly things really
kind of just eerie. Very often
workers would catch glimpses of
her when working outside. They'd
see a silhouette of a young
woman in the window, the same
window she was set to sit in
with like a really sad look and
something interesting. It said
that people who notice her in
that context are overcome with a
sense of sadness. And the owner,
Bob, has claimed that he's even
seen people just start to cry
like out of nowhere, just be
affected that much by the, I
don't know, by the atmosphere of
her presence that they just
start to weep. And the stories
go on from there. I mean, there
are stories of the one night in
like August of 1980. It's really
hot out. You know, when
sometimes there's like
lightning, even though there's
no rain and it's really humid
out like heat lightning. Yeah,
that's fake, but continue. What
do you mean? Oh, it's not. No,
but a lot of people believe that
because it's hot out, that there
is lightning caused by the heat,
but it's actually just far away
lightning. That is very
interesting. Okay, so there's
far away lightning. And all the
lights in the house go out and
all the workers go outside and
they're like, oh, what's going
on? And they turn and they see,
even though all the lights are
out, there's no power in the
window of the old field room on
the second floor, the lights are
on and it's almost like a candle
light, like a flickering sort of
light. And they watch as the
shape of a young woman, long
hair, just a silhouette, walks
across the window. And all of a
sudden the lights go back on in
the house. They rush back in,
you know, they go up there. Of
course, there's no one there. A
lot of weird stuff like that. A
lot of full-on apparitions of
this ghost, sights of her
silhouette, sights of her
upfront, playful things like,
you know, the tie clip
disappearing or candles,
relighting themselves, that
chair being thrown across. Yeah,
just playful. Yeah. And they
always hear stuff like footsteps
and all sorts of things. In
fact, I saw an account of a
worker who claimed to have
worked there back in the day who
claimed that basically on some
quiet nights after like closing,
the workers would just like hang
out at the bar there and have
fun just waiting for something
to happen. Like this stuff was
that common. They'd hear voices,
they'd hear footsteps, they'd
hear or they'd see silhouettes,
they'd see things move. And the
wine cellar in the basement
supposedly wine bottles
sometimes will just fly off the
walls and wine glasses will
smash in front of people's
faces. And it's all checked up
to Annette Williamson. That
would happen at my work. The
heck? Do you? Right. Now when
you have to clean it. True.
Yeah. But so yeah, there's just
a lot of stuff here. And one of
the craziest claims I've heard
is that like when people listen
to music in the restaurant at
night, like the owner will have
like a radio on, the ghost of
Annette will mess with the radio
because she loves music. And
she'll turn the knobs and
they'll be like, Annette, what
are you doing? So evidently she
loves music. She loves kids. She
loves music. All great. Crank up
some AC DC that they put on
after closing. Exactly. She just
jams out to some classic rock.
That's kind of interesting that
she's very, you know, attached
to the music kind of thing
because radios weren't really
too common or I don't even think
they were a thing back then.
Yeah, it's good. Yeah. So I
don't, I mean, obviously people
had music for centuries and
centuries, but it's interesting
to think that new technology is
impacting the old behaviors of
the ghost. Ghosts can learn. You
think that means they can use
iPhones as well? They could like
pause your Spotify. No, but they
might be able to type in the
chat GPT if they possess your
computer. That is just what chat
GPT is. AI are just ghosts.
Yeah, it's just like ghosts. But
great. So we have all these
accounts. I mean, you even have
accounts of people, like random
people driving by at night and
seeing the silhouette of Annette
Williamson in the window and
being overcome with sadness. So
from a distance. While the yeah,
so while the original story kind
of comes from that French
sidekick that passes to the
owner and then the Carrie Anne
and Joe kind of running with it
and claiming to be in contact
with her when they visit, you
don't have just sightings
limited to those people. You
have normal if you look at the
reviews on Google Maps of this
place and you search for haunted
or ghost, people will reference
her and be like, love the
atmosphere, love the friendly
spirits, love Annette, always
great to visit her. And it's
like, it's weird. So I'd love to
go there. I think this summer we
should try going there. If you
guys come down, we'll visit it.
Yeah. Well, quick question. You
said so like, I'm still hung up
on that throwing the chair. Has
anyone been hurt? Because you
know, you hear stories of people
getting scratched or like being
pushed downstairs with like
these kind of more also these
poltergeist things. So I'm just
wondering if someone's been hurt
and then like they also just
chalk it up to Annette when I
mean, there are reviews saying,
oh, she's great. We love her.
That's a good question. I think
not good for business,
obviously. So they might not
really. So yeah, so that's an
interesting point. The business
will always tell like the cute,
the cutesy stories about
Annette. Paranormal
investigators that come to visit
and write books often tell more
of the other stories like EVPs
that might have more the ones
I've listened to stuff are just
voices saying, come. So not not
spooky, but the like the
restaurant doesn't advertise the
throwing chair story. Well,
yeah, I mean, I was just curious
if any, you know, yeah, no, I
don't I haven't heard of any
other violent things besides
throwing wine glasses and wine
bottles off. That's that's kind
of that's not peaceful. I'm
wondering if it very well could
be Annette in both the peaceful
and, you know, a little bit more
violent scenarios. I'm wondering
if she's just reacts to people
differently. Like she may see,
you know, a white strong man and
think, OK, you're probably one
of the British. I don't really
like you because you got me in
and killed or, you know, maybe
one of the townspeople that had
her hung or executed, maybe
someone looked like that. And
that's what caused the reaction.
Yeah, she kind of taking taking
her biases to the grave.
Discriminatory. Well, we have
all this evidence of Annette
Williamson, her tragic story,
her tragic tale, her poor
family. Right. You think like
there'd be a lot of spirits at
this place for her whole family.
So all the kids, the parents
killed in New Jersey. There's no
worse way to go out than being
killed in New Jersey by British
people. All right. Wow. True.
Wait. That's only half of the
story because as far as I can
tell, Annette Williamson never
existed. Oh, good. She doesn't
exist. So is it like a publicity
stunt from the restaurant? I
don't know. Well, this was a
story from the French psychic,
right? Let's let's roll back.
Let's go to this guy all the way
back. Let's roll all the way
back to the history of this
place. So I found the history of
this place back to 1710. All
different people. It's passed
down through the entire history
of Stony Brook, the families
there, the development of Stony
Brook, the historical figures
here. And as I started reading
the story of Annette Williamson,
while also the history of Stony
Brook and the house and the
ownership, I was like, wait a
minute, this doesn't all this
doesn't make sense. And I found
a great blog post that pointed
this out too, and did some
digging and I did some digging
based on that. So there are a
bunch of inconsistencies with
the Annette story that we're
going to go into. Wonderful.
Number one, there was never a
Williamson family that owns the
property. That's a pretty big
red flag. You just checked that
with like deed like records.
Yeah. So at the time, the Davis
family who originally built the
property still owned it. They
owned it for like four
generations. So well past the
American Revolution, it was
owned by the Davis family.
That's like a hundred years at
least. Yeah, right. So there
wasn't a Williamson family that
owned it. There was a Williamson
family that lived in the area,
actually around the corner. I
was just about to ask if they
were like friends or neighbors
or something. They were
neighbors, but that was in like
the early to mid 1800s, nowhere
near 1776. On top of that, the
name Annette just wasn't used at
the time. That is not a name
that was used in the colonies
slash America. Well, are there
in the late 1700s? There are
like almost no records of that
name. And there wouldn't be any
like census records going back
that far really. There actually
are. There actually are a lot of
death records and that. We're
gonna get into that but not like
US census, you know, because
that wasn't a thing. Yeah, there
are records, but yeah, they're
pretty flaky. But I was able to
find the Williamson's that lived
there and died there, which
we'll talk about in a moment.
But on top of that, even before
we get to the damning evidence,
Annette isn't a common name at
the time. Williamson isn't a
Dutch last name. It's English
and Scottish. Okay. So the name
Annette isn't the last name
isn't Dutch. The name wasn't
used for like generations later.
The family never owned the
property. There was the family
that lived in the area
generations later. So I'm
wondering, how can this story,
there's so many questions from
that. Like people see the ghost
of Annette Williamson. Yeah, or
something. They see her. They
see something that fits the
description of Annette and it's
mostly hanged in. Right? So I
descends out that the evidence
that's proposed for this story
is that if you go to the Oba
Diah Davis cemetery in the back
of their property, you'll see
the Williamson family tombstones
and you'll see in the net,
you'll see a John Williamson and
then the net Williamson. Let me
send you guys the link here. I
found the tombs and pictures of
the tombs. So they do have them.
The people buried here. You just
can't visit there, but there are
pictures of the stuff in the
cemetery. It seems like you can
ask to go there. And what's
interesting, the reason we have
these pictures and the dates and
the names is because a
descendant of Oba Diah Davis
living today went there and
documented it all on this
website, find a grave and
documented all his ancestors and
the other people who lived here.
Have you guys scroll through
this list, which I'll have in
the show notes. Do you guys see
Annette Williamson? I see a
Hannah, a John, and a William
Williamson, real creative guys.
And when did they die? The mid
1800s. Yep. We've got 1827 for
Hannah, 1844 for John, 1831 for
William. It just doesn't line
up. There's no Annette
Williamson. There weren't
Williamson's that died in this
area or on that property that
time. Now, let me play devil's
advocate for a quick second and
give some highly unplausible
explanation. Yeah, of course.
But it could be very well that
there may have been an Annette
Williamson, but there could have
been something that happened,
like some kind of illegitimate
marriage or birth or something
with her involved. And of
course, back then, you know,
women didn't really have a lot
going for them. So if there was
a situation like that, you know,
she would probably get in the
most, you know, trouble if
anything like that happened
rather than the man. So it could
have just been like something
happened. They didn't want that,
you know, quote stain on their
family. And maybe it's she could
have just been buried in some
unmarked grave. That's I know,
again, far fetched. But like,
well, see my she was that my
issue with that is there are
Williamson tombstones there like
Frank has shown us. Right. And
they're well past the date of
the American Revolution, which
doesn't add up with the story of
them all dying. Like supposedly
the the way that Frank has told
the first half of the story is
that the bloodline of the
Williamson, at least in that
area, died out that night. Yeah.
I mean, the only thing I could
say to that would be like, maybe
the psychic got it wrong and it
was the Civil War and some
Southerners or some Southern
sympathizers killed them. That's
that's actually again, this is
that's just solely yeah, she did
exist and just trying to come up
with something about maybe why
she's not there. Very unlikely
that any of this I never thought
of the ballot. Yeah, I mean,
even the civil like, because
yeah, that but even then that's
still before the great the
deaths of the people that still
before so like, again, just to
think of something about maybe
why she could be, you know, a
real person. Yeah. That's that's
an important thing to know. It
definitely is possible that
there was an Annette Williamson
who lived maybe, right, maybe
they didn't own the property,
maybe, maybe parts of the story
are true, right? Yeah. And yes,
maybe we just don't have the
records of it and it doesn't
line up. Maybe there is a spirit
of her whatever reason still
there. However, given what
evidence does exist, when you
look into it, there actually is
no physical evidence to support
the story. At all. Everything
unfortunately came from that one
original psychic, as far as I
can tell, and the follow up
psychics and mediums that claim
to be in contact. Do we have the
name of the original French
psychic or I could not find it
now. If I can find it, I'll put
in the show. The asking. Do you
remember what that guy's name
was? I am actually debating
calling up the restaurant or
sending an email and not being,
you know, critical and saying,
the story you tell us. No, of
course. He doesn't. What is true
is that people see something,
right? They experience
something. They see a ghost of a
young woman. They see stuff fly
off shelves. They get chairs,
chairs, they get candles, relit.
They see things. They hear
things. They experience things.
That's I don't doubt. Right. Me
neither. Then what's going on?
We have an unidentified spookum.
What is going on? Isn't that I
feel like that's even more
interesting than it being true.
Personally, I think story of an
interesting things. They just
don't make sense. Why would the
whole, like the British soldiers
just murdered a bunch of babies,
like a bunch of kids. They're
not monsters. Why did the
parents die? But the historical
record clear. I mean, I found
documents from Stony Brook going
back to like that were published
in like 1907, showing pictures
and giving the history. And
there's never ever any
historical record, any mention
of a Williamson family owning
it. It's always Obadiah Davis
for generations and Thomas
Hadaway for many years. Then
what's going on? Right.
Unfortunately, I think some
people are being a little
untruthful for maybe different
reasons. That is the psychics
claim that if you go to the
cemetery, you will see her
tombstone. That's just not true.
The two psychics, I forget their
name. Yeah. I watched an hour
and a half long presentation by
them and I feel like I'm I'll
link to in the show notes. I
hope no one, I hope this doesn't
get back to them. But they talk
about, I mean, I went through
that video and I found just, I
kept track of all the things
that were, that appeared to be
factually incorrect with what
they were saying. They had a
little slideshow. They claimed
that there's only two tombstones
of Williamson's at the cemetery.
And one of them is Annette. The
other one is John. That's not
true. There's three. And there's
no Annette. Maybe, I don't know,
how do you get Annette from like
Hannah or John or Willy? Is
there any weird, like old, old,
like translation or something of
like Annette to Hannah in any
way? Not that I even see. I
don't think so. Yeah. Doesn't
sound very likely. But the only
thing some related to that is of
the Dutch last name. So like
they could maybe they're, you
know, because I point out it's
not even the Dutch name. It
could, you know, it could have
been a Dutch name that was
turned into a more English name.
Perhaps. In the colonies. But
yeah, just really, it doesn't
line up. But it makes me wonder
because you've got EVPs of the
voices. You've got, you've got
psychics claiming to be in
contact with her, claiming to
see her, claiming to have her
tell them the story. Right. The
original psychic claimed
Annette, Annette spirit told him
her terribly sad story. So
what's going on? Right. Is it? I
don't think everyone's just
pretending. I don't think it's
hallucinations. No, I never
liked that explanation either.
The hallucinations. Is it the
story has generated the
experiences that people see? Is
that possible? Is it that the
story of a young 17 year old
Annette Williamson with long
blonde hair, blue eyes that
haunts because of this story.
Did that generate a ghost that
people now see? What do you guys
think? I have two things when
they do the EVP or when the, I
guess when the, you know, you
can't really know what the
psychics are hearing from the
spirits or whatever, I guess.
But when they say like, Oh, do
they say, Oh, Annette, are you
here? Like, do they specifically
say, okay. Because I'm gonna say
if they just say nothing related
to her name. Yep. No, it's, it
is the address Annette. They
mentioned the story. I even
watched a YouTube video of some
kid from six years ago who would
go around long on with his
grandma who was psychic and he
would bring an EVP meter and go
into haunted places and go in
this place. He'd go, Annette,
are you there? His voice is kind
of funny. I feel bad for
laughing at him, but it's very
funny. I'll put it in the show
notes. Annette, are you there?
And then you hear like the thing
go off and he's grandma,
grandma, grandma, come here.
It's really weird. Grandma and
grandson, paranormal
investigating duo. And his dad
and his uncle are part of their
production. It's pretty cool.
It's a family business, but it
is the guy's voice is funny.
What do you think? So one thing
that I was considering, which
still doesn't completely make
the story lineup, perhaps
because the entire family was
killed and, you know, there was
no like next of kin to bury
them. Perhaps the British
soldiers just took them and
dumped them with other bodies or
oh wait, no, it was the
townspeople that killed them.
Wasn't it? But maybe that works
though. Cause yeah, the story is
that they were so pissed at the
Williamson's that they killed
them all. So maybe, yeah, maybe
they wouldn't give them a proper
burial. Yeah. So, you know,
maybe they, their bodies and
therefore records have gone
unnoticed. What about the other
tombs though, that are
Williamson's? Is that just like
a later branch of that family? I
mean, it's, it's not like an
unheard of name. That's, yeah.
You know, and given that their
names are what would be John and
Hannah and William and William.
William Williamson. Well, you
got to start the last name
somewhere, but those all sound a
lot more English names. So
perhaps it's just a coincidence
and there's a different family
of Williamson's. That'd be
interesting, but they're also in
the same exact area at the same
time. It's unlikely, but yeah,
it's definitely possible. I
never, honestly, thinking about
like maybe the time period is
off or that those were two
theories that just never crossed
my mind when doing all this
research. I was like, this is
ridiculous. There's no such
person. It's, it's a lie. But
no, there definitely are, who
knows, right? I think there's
something or some things that
haunt the country house
restaurant in Stony Brook, New
York. I don't know what the
mindset in Stony Brook is
looking for, but it doesn't like
how it's King and how long has
it gone apart. And so that's
Liam Simon thanks for joining on
this episode The PHONE KID It's
popular enough in Long Island
and enough people believe it and
give a lot of credence to it and
think about it while they're
there. Those thoughts being so
concentrated on that could
create like a topic entity and
it's manifesting as this Annette
Williamson that really isn't
there. And that lines up with
there not being any records or
anything like that. Then where
do you think the original story
do you think that French psychic
was just like yeah I want a free
meal let me just there's a
spirit here. Annette Williamson
let me let me tell you the tale
over a dinner. You think you
just made up a story and Annette
we don't know anything about
that. We don't know anything
about the French psych. Yeah I
got to find we got to find that
guy. Yeah or we got to find
Annette. Yeah. Oh I would love
to go and evidently people just
show up or talk to the guy and
he lets them like do paranormal
investigations like the owner is
very obviously it's like a great
marketing thing right. He's
really into it. Also he really
people are people are
experiencing things like we've
been saying something's
happening. Oh yeah there is it
there's stuff there. It's if
it's a Topa that's people have
thought because people thought
it's Annette and that's what's
happening then sure but if it's
not and there's something else
at play maybe again there could
be there are plenty of
undocumented deaths that happen
and I'm sure back then it was
probably more common. Not saying
no records were taken. It wasn't
that long ago but could be an
undocumented death and it's just
matching the same description.
The Annette thing could have
just been made up. Who knows
like the actual name like it
could be like a person could
still have died there but maybe
her name wasn't Annette. That's
true. Well final thoughts Aaron.
When are we going down to this
restaurant. It's my final
thoughts. Give me let's let's
say a few months. I will go I
will call I'll say Bob. Bob you
lying to me. Let me see. Show me
the grave Bob. Show me Annette
Williamson. It's in your
backyard. You know I would love
to get to buy on that. It's also
weird that there's kind of aside
from the story that this is
what's called Long Island's you
know quote most haunted location
when there's all those stories
and conspiracy theories of what
happened out on like Montauk.
That's like why those are gonna
be great stories for another
time. Like why like when I think
of like you know spooky things
or just weird things in Long
Island I think of Montauk. I
don't think of this restaurant
in Stony Brook. We'll have to
record another episode on that.
Yeah you're right I think maybe
this is um it's very accessible.
I guess. Yeah it's like right
you can tell us the kids you
tell it to uh to adults. It's
yeah it's like something that
right we're not saying like
Bigfoot lives in shore on the
New York. He might you don't
know. Oh he might. There's not
enough people in the summer
home. In those artificial woods
down on Long Island. Bigfoot in
the Hamptons. That sounds like a
movie or a book or something.
Sounds like yeah I think maybe
that's you know it's easy to
market. It's like a great
touristy thing too. But yeah
something's going on there. I
think it'd be great if we had a
nice dinner there and uh kept an
eye out for her. And Annette
threw a knife at you. Okay
butter knife. Maybe just like
change the channel on the radio.
That's good. Change the channel.
The craziest claim I heard from
Joe the media psychic or
whatever was that he has EVPs
where you hear the background
music of the restaurant playing.
And it will cut from that to the
voice of a young woman singing.
Just no music at all just her
singing. I don't know what he
meant. Oh good. I never one
thing couldn't find recordings.
Like a personal thing for me
EVPs always are so shaky for me.
Like all the audio evidence that
like you know plenty of the
ghost shows do and like even on
like I love like the BuzzFeed
unsolved guys what they what
they did. Yeah like but they
still do like the EVP things. I
never really liked that you know
and I you know I believe in
ghosts and that a lot of people
experience a lot of weird
things. I have friends that have
experienced things but like
those audio recording things I
don't put a lot of a lot of
credence into what those give.
So I'm always hesitant when
someone says oh look at the CVP
because even like you said it
said oh come. Ah yes one. Yeah
those are the ones that are
those that's just such the
classic EVP. I'll put them in
the astronauts. Where you get
one word. It may be two. You
never get full sentences but the
full sentences you get might
come from like psychics but then
now you have to put all your
belief in this one person and
apparently at least with these
psychics they just missed the
mark. Yeah that makes you wonder
like are they just picking up on
that like you said Nick like
that thought form that's out
there like are they just picking
up on what's around. It's not
necessarily weird. True. Like if
you like okay so say like that
you know they can contact the
dead like psychics or mediums.
It'd be weird for them to be
able to be in contact with
something that's not dead. It's
you know it's a it's a if it is
like a tulp idea that's just
like energy from people's
thoughts. You think so? I think
I mean unless it I mean you can
go into all this kind of
different how you know energies
work and. Aaron should tell us
as the electrical engineer how
energy works. How energy works.
You want to lose viewers with
that one? Which is like it'd be
it's weird to think that like me
like people that say they're
mediums that's the connotation
that they talk to the dead. If
it's a tulpa that's not a dead
thing. It's the idea of a dead
thing. That's it. I guess not
the person but. I understand
what you're saying. So you're
saying if mediums can do what
they claim they would really
only be communicating with dead
spirits not with other you know
quote made up spirits because
it's again there's a lot of
energy that goes into like this
creation of a tulpa like you
know the Tibetan monks where
this started you know monks you
know they live a very solitary
life but they can be very
focused. So they put a lot of
thought into whatever entity
they want to create and then
they create that tulpa. So like
like I said if a lot of people
are doing that maybe not a lot
of thought but if a lot of
people are putting some thought
into it it's still just this
build up of you know thought
energy. It's it's the equivalent
of a spiritual think tank but
just instead of. Did you have
that written down? No I did not.
It was like you know a lot of
people are just thinking about
it. It'd be weird that psychics
could pick up on like thought
forms rather than spirits
because then that makes you
wonder for all these like
classic haunted places even down
there like Amityville and all
that the psychics that go there
are they picking up on spirits
or on tulpas if because if a lot
of people are thinking about
things and you believe in that
idea of a tulpa it's not
entirely out of the realm of
possibility that that's what it
is and there aren't actually
any. That's interesting. Yeah I
they came they both came across
as very sincere and very
confident but some of the things
that they said were just
factually wrong so it makes you
wonder right it really makes you
wonder I think that there's
still enough questions that are
left unanswered here. I'm gonna
keep digging a little bit and
maybe we'll report back one day
but I think it would be great to
visit see if we expensive meal
hopefully it'd be good. Maybe if
we're nice we could visit the
cemetery if we say if we
impersonate FBI agents as Nick
says. I'm telling you it's a
surefire way for illegal
purposes that's a joke. Yeah yes
wink. That's the story of
Annette Williamson and I have to
say it made me wonder that the
very first story I decided to
research and tell was such a
well-known story in Long Island
that also proved to be on very
shaky historical ground. Really
makes you think. So I'm very
curious to see in the things I
research next I'm gonna be
looking more at things in the
Bronx in my hometown and also
Long Island stuff because
there's just a lot of history
there. Is that going to be a
common theme or is this an
outlier? So tune in to the next
episodes looking forward to what
you guys have in store.
Hopefully there's less deception
by psychics and mediums. And
what I have coming up from what
I've done there are no psychics
involved. It's more the
retelling of others accounts of
a very large cemetery right in
Schenectady here in the capital
region. Oh we can go there too.
Yes and you can visit there it's
a very and you can walk through
there even at night it is just
like public and you know people
have taken it for like shortcuts
and things but there are a lot
of a lot of like individual
accounts of things happening
there and a lot of that's much
more on the negative side of
things and kind of the the
playfulness that this and that
has exhibited. Awesome. That's
what we'll be looking at from
me. Yeah from my upcoming story
we're gonna be real local to us.
We're gonna be looking at RPI
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute
where there's legend of a nurse
Betsy haunting one of the
women's bad but no one really
knows all that much about it but
there's been some paranormal
investigators that came full up.
I'm looking forward to that.
That's gonna be great. That's
gonna be spooky. So yeah great
looking forward to next episodes
and I hope everyone enjoyed
hearing about Annette
Williamson. I encourage you to
go go over there and try to talk
to her and ask her what she
thinks about this. Maybe play
this on play this episode on the
radio for her there and see if
she changes the channel. That's
all for tonight. Check out the
show notes and all references
used at Wednesday at 9 p.m. com.
We hope you enjoyed the show and
we'll see you next week. 3 1 14
20 20 18 21 19 20 28 5 6 18 5 14
3 8